foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey it's always weird when I do this
without Kevin because Kevin is the one
who just jumps in here like a barrel of
energy and uh and and exhorts me to
action however today on this episode of
black man beyond
um I do not have Kevin's uh once again
otherwise we wouldn't call it this
um he is uh as as he's prone to do often
the world doing Kev [__]
um which means that it falls to me to
hold it down for the good folks in pound
town
um and do another episode of black man
beyond
um I'm fairly excited about this episode
for a couple of different reasons
um the the not the least of which is
that we get to talk about a bunch of new
trailers we get to talk about the the
Guardians 3 trailer the fast X trailer
and the little running guy Fast trailer
um we get to talk about uh Last of Us
two episodes episodes four and five uh
last time we were here with with Tiffany
Smith we talked about uh the the
Heartbreak of episode three and then
we'll get into more heartbreak because
it seems like that's what this show is
all about
um but and I think I've mentioned it
before on on the podcast that uh that
when I was when I was a wee lab
in high school
um and Junior High in Long Island New
York town called Baldwin
um that's where I grew up I was born in
the Bronx I grew up in Baldwin
um I was your average standard Misfit
um who never quite you know the the
Legos never matched in the right holes
and so I I I skittered through a bunch
of social Social Circles I played on a
football team I was at the drama Squad I
you know loved comic books I played
dozen dragons like I played basketball
in the Summers like I was I was that
weird polyglot kind of kid
um and consequently my my musical tastes
in like the mid 80s were a little bit
all over the place there was
um Jazz and and Motown from my parents
and there was sort of the the pop of the
day you know rap was beginning to feel
itself in in a large in a large way you
know Run DMC and LL Cool J and on the on
the heels of like Grandmaster Flash and
furious five and all that stuff and and
so and music for me
but it never really quite fit all of the
things that I was and so there were a
couple of artists over the course of of
that development period when the the
clay was still wet when the story the
soil was still fertile who sort of
unlocked for me the me that I could be
in the world the things that I could
love in the world and not have to
apologize to anybody for loving it
um Prince I think was the first one who
kind of opened the door for me in that
way that you could be
black and you could play guitar and you
could play since and you could Rock and
you could be
flowery and you could be in touch with
every element of your sexuality that you
could you could be sort of the like a
black David Bowie even though David
Bowie was his own weird alien self
um
and and the other one you know and we'll
we'll hit this very hard towards the end
of the podcast
was De La Soul
um which sort of opened up for me a rap
that did not have to be about machismo
it did not have to be about braggadocio
it did not have to be about chains and
and boom boxes and all that stuff it
could be about whatever the hell you
wanted it to be about
um and it could still bang as hard as
[__]
um and then sort of the Third
element of that the Third Leg of that
table the third wall of that pyramid for
me was was Living Color like Living
Color got to be the the hardest version
of that Living Color got to [__] go
hard you know but go hard in the way
that you know Zeppelin went hard go hard
in the way that [__] Megadeth went
hard go hard in the way that like rock
and metal and all that [__] can go hard
but also be black as [__] and
unapologetically so and be the first
time I got to see that in the world
um there were no music videos of black
rock bands before I saw called the
personality and MTV it just didn't
happen and and it was this sort of
tectonic shift in the who I was going to
be and then I could like everything I
could like all of it and all of it could
then in turn be available to me and I
didn't have to feel weird for it I
didn't have to feel Outcast because of
it and and so I just Incorporated it and
it helped to calibrate the sort of
compass of my life in who I was going to
be and how I was going to conduct myself
and and it's always been there like
those three pillars of that part of pop
culture
still remain inviolent to me they are
the things that made me who I am and
allowed me to like the things that I
like and to fall in love with things
that I would never really wouldn't have
and so one of the weird side effects of
getting to do a podcast like this is
occasionally
um and my life is weird in any number of
ways but you do get to collide in the
most wonderful ways with your Heroes and
I have to date never really been let
down by them
um maybe I don't have enough Heroes so
maybe maybe my uh the the sample set
isn't big enough for me to get
um completely heartbroken by it but uh
but every now and again you get to to
have an interaction with somebody who
meant something to you an incredible
amount to you as a kid and then discover
that in the oddest of [__] ways that
you have meant something to them as well
and so it is it is with like humility
and honor and awe and joy that I get to
welcome Corey Glover
to co-host this episode of black man
beyond with me
oh hey man
how are you what's happening I'm awake
um yeah we got it there we finally got
there you called me a couple times was
like nope can't do it no you don't want
to do it can't do it but I'm here now
and of course this morning I had oral
surgery I had two teeth yanked out of my
face so don't mind me don't mind me I'm
gonna be loud my face hurts
uh well thank you for uh for doing
um oral Agony to come and hang out with
me no problem this is much better than
having somebody drilling into my face
uh that is exactly the kind of uh of A
and B that I like to exist in how you
doing you're better than drilling me in
the face
okay
then I win you win absolutely
but yes thank you very much I know you
were on tour last week you were you were
on the road
um I've been I've been doing a lot of
running around I was out with uh
two fourths of Soul Asylum doing this
acoustic thing when I was doing my solo
some of my solo work and I'm always
contractually obligated to play a Living
Color song no matter where I go it
doesn't matter
um so doing that and before that I was
on this Cruise called Shiprock shout out
to them and it was so I was on a boat
for like five six days so and every time
you called I was like nope not here
nope not home shitty Wi-Fi everywhere I
go oh nope can't do it
well
um I'm glad I'm glad it happened I'm
glad we got it together
um and I'm going to I'm going to do my
best to not Chris Farley my way through
this
remember that time you you were on tour
the stone is always awesome
yeah
listen man if whenever you want to
whenever you drop me a nugget I will I
will gladly take it
um but where you know where did your
nerd come in where where what's your way
in
it was
uh I am
the
youngest child
and my brother
my brother and sister are over 10 years
younger than 10 years older than I am
so I basically grew up around adults
and but
I loved
weird [__] I loved uh comic books aren't
weird [__] but I was like into falconry
I got yeah yeah in Brooklyn in Brooklyn
wow in Brooklyn well that was just rats
get a glove for pigeons it was horrible
it's horrible pigeonly right I was in
the archery I read a book somewhere
about archery and I just lost my mind
and thought I was gonna be like the
Green Arrow you know just running across
the rooftops with with a bow and arrow
it was weird it was weird
um
but
I was always my family was always
somewhat artistically inclined my sister
was an actress and my brother was a
singer
so somehow I was gonna do one of one of
both one of both of those things at some
point in time in my life
and because
I was dealing with older people my
conversations to people my age were
never right
were like what are you talking about why
do you sound like that why do you talk
that way
you know and I got I I got the the
obligatory you know sound black you know
constantly and
what's What's your deal and all that
stuff until I found a few people that I
knew were just like me like
and and I found the variations of them
like I found
you know larpers like I had a friend
that was a larper didn't tell anybody
who didn't tell a soul that he was a
larper until I saw him in the park I was
like John
I was like I found out he was like he's
in his in his cardboard armor running
around and like wow
and I had lots of friends that were
musicians that were like players and
that you know
when I was younger they were never
around to hang out with because it was
already taking lessons but then when
they got we got to be teenagers they got
into bands and then and for myself I got
into choirs like I got the church choirs
and and I got into all City High School
chorus
and
then I had a friend that I was in a
choir when the church choirs I was in
who turned me on to Bad Brains and I
lost it when he turned me on the Bad
Brains and fishbone I was like this
that's it that's me I got it there I am
and I found myself I really really found
myself in that and I went to a hardcore
matinee when I was like 18 or 19.
and was transfixed to watch Bad Brains
in action
and I have not looked back ever since
so I come to it pretty I come to my geek
them
pretty honestly
you know I mean I think I think
everybody does you know because I don't
at all want to gatekeep I don't know you
know I mean I do I remember the refrain
when I was like 20 years old I was like
where all the ladies at
why are there no ladies here you know
and like I don't understand the social
forces that might have driven some of
those women underground I bet you they
look like comic book store owners who
you know had tests to allow people to
walk in right gatekeeping was real
um but I think that everybody who loves
it loves it because they love it like
you wouldn't choose it if you could you
know definitely not if you're in your
50s like it was not it was not easy to
be a nerd back in the 80s
no no no there's a lot of running
involved in that
a lot of running like
because comic book shops were in some
weird ass neighborhoods that I was not
allowed to be in after a certain time so
I had to run or I remember
like in my 20s there was a club in
Brooklyn called lamors and the way you
got to lemurs as a black person is you
took the D train to a certain stop and
you ran to the club
because you because the neighborhood was
a gauntlet
you know so you ran and hid and ran and
hid until you got to got to the club you
got into the club and then you start
then you did just stretching for after
the gig and it's like okay I'm going
back to the train station now
so we had to run back to the train
station so yeah it was not easy in like
the 80s to be in that to want to go to a
hardcore matinee or even go see some
even if you wanted to go see something
that was not on the Beaten Track like
like I said I'm from Brooklyn and
everything that you listened to was
gatekeeped was that they kept they
definitely kept that and if you said
something outside of that
there was work you just got it like that
I could talk about
you know a kiss record in the same way
that I could talk about
you know a Keith Sweat record
drove people crazy
you know they don't know what to do with
you right you know
I like them both
I do
yeah uh and also like Kiss was Kiss was
a good like
if you're a nerd kiss speaks to you even
if you don't even before you get to the
music which is not [__] bad like I I
swung around to kiss like listening to
it later on but I was all about the
theatricality I was all about the makeup
I was all about the demon and the blood
and the tongue and the brush like all of
them spoke to an eight-year-old and the
kitty cat I didn't understand that but
it didn't have to
um why are you a cat
and drummer's cat drummer okay you got
it let's go yeah I mean for for somebody
who liked Josie and the Pussycats this
was right in line
they went 70 band waiting to happen
right and so now how old how old were
you when uh when Living Color when when
you joined when you inverted and Muslim
again
I was maybe 22 23 years old like
I got into the band and this is this is
the the story I tell everybody is I got
into the band because I sang Happy
Birthday
and how that went was I was at
somebody's party
and
I was talking to some people and they
wheeled out a cake and the person whose
birthday it was said nope nobody's
singing Happy Birthday that guy is and
it was like I'm going to give you a
really rough reference but it was like
that girl
um and I was like huh what what okay so
I say happy birthday and Vern happened
to be there with his sister
and we struck up a conversation we
exchanged phone numbers
and it turns out that he lived like six
or seven blocks away from me
and we both lived in Crown Heights and
he lived on Empire Boulevard I lived on
Brooklyn Avenue so
um
he invited me over one day and plays me
some of this music and this is the first
time I heard so I was like I want to
know and funny vibe and he was like
we need a singer for this band I've been
singing and I'm really not doing a
really good job so we need a new we need
to we need a full-fledged singer to do
this do this kind of thing it's like all
right I'm down I'm so down I'm so down
and I auditioned for it
and he said don't worry I'll call you in
a couple weeks and let you know whether
you got it or not and we'll either way
one way or the other I'll let you know
okay so a week went by and three weeks
went by and a month went by and two
months went by then I got a phone call
from Vernon saying our singer can't do
the gig can you do it
and that is the nature of my
relationship with Vernon Reed
I went down we rehearsed and
um
we did the gig
and the guy never came the the real lead
singer never came back so I've been
stuck with this job since then
so I you know it is easy for me to
imagine only because you know as a
person who is like read a bunch of music
coverage he's watched a bunch of
documentaries and [__] to imagine what
22 23 24 years old is like suddenly
you're on stages suddenly you're on a
read it suddenly you're traveling the
world
what the [__] man
your guess is as good as mine how to do
what happened that [__] was I have no
[__] idea what happened all of a
sudden
you know
we went this is this is the really weird
thing we went from traveling in bands
like we were in you know Econoline
church vans driving up and down the east
coast and driving West and driving
around to being on tour buses and
playing in stadiums we played in places
that are big as their living room
up until the point you know the stones
called and said you want to do this like
hell yeah and we were on stages you
could fit all of the places we played
around the country in one Stadium
so we went from Feast to famine really
really quickly and while this was all
going on
our relationship to MTV's
had drastically changed like we had um
we had a hard time like with the first
single and
and they're like MTV was not
particularly interested they played it
late at night it was like it was a
glorified radio station at the time and
and they just were not feeling us really
and then and we said we were telling
them you know put out cultural
personality it'll it'll be it's a really
good song I think it'll work we think
it'll work
and lo and behold it did but it there
was some behind the scenes politicking
going on that we didn't have no idea
until after the fact
because we were on the same label as
Michael Jackson
ah
and the guy the head of promotion
sort of hinted to the program director
at MTV is like it'd be ashamed if
Michael Jackson didn't get put on them
TVs this week if the Living Color
doesn't get put on so
so
yeah you figure that out okay see you
later bye now
the nerd in me now wants to know
um what country
that you visited is the best place to be
a nerd
best place to be a nerd like is it Japan
I feel like Japan is always a Hot Topic
Japan is on top of that list because you
can get anything out of a vending
machine out of Japan
wow
anything
anything I need a ball peen hammer right
there I gotta go pick up a hallway full
of people I need a ball right right
it's like they're like
they're music places there was a store
those last time I was there that you
could go
and say I want this I want this record I
want that record I want this record I
want that record and they will
make you an MP3 that you can then
download at some point in a mix the way
you want to hear it
most amazing [__] I ever saw in my life
Wow
um so you can pick you can get your own
mixtapes made in this I mean some of
these places and like
um to go get gadgets and I was a freak I
am still a freak for gadgets
like anything you can think of a
left-handed nose clipper whatever you're
looking for
it's there it's there and probably in a
vending machine and
yeah Japan is Japan is number one on
that list but you know you go to places
strangely enough like London you'll find
it it's more it's really expensive but
it's in but it's in London
um
buenos Argentina
don't know why
but I have no but you can find all kinds
of geek [__] in Buenos Aires
I don't know why I don't I really don't
understand why
they got nerds but they got nerds they
got tons of nerds they obviously have a
[__] ton of nerds in Argentina
um where else can you find
Toronto
um
why am I blinking on the name is also in
Canada
uh
Vancouver Montreal Alberta
Montreal not so much Alberta not so much
but
Vancouver and Toronto
are like
geek headquarters West Coast and East
Coast evidently
um
it wouldn't surprise me if like that's
that's a weird Hollywood byproduct right
like everybody who's going up north from
here to go shoot their show for like
five months like this one I need a store
I need my [__] I need my fix like you
gotta open up a good [__]
role-playing spot right I need my
figurines I got I got my Minifigs I
gotta paint do you have is there a DND
card store anywhere around
I need
my Mages card I need new Mages cards all
kinds of [__] yeah Toronto definitely
you can do that yeah Canada in general
is sort of like geeky world it's geek
world
you know Canada
but you can be but you can be geek on so
many different levels like you can be a
hockey geek and make no sense whatsoever
right that makes no sense to me I didn't
understood hockey I never did it's
hockey I've known for instance anybody
who likes hockey but hockey is just a
lot a lot hockey's a lot I never dug it
I grew up on um you know again
if you're on Long Island if you're in
the city then you got like the Islanders
and the and the Rangers to deal with and
if you're close enough to Jersey the
Jersey Jersey Devils like you're always
on a train with a bunch of people coming
out of the exact station I love the
garden I love the jerseys the jerseys
are really cool and there was a point in
time when when hockey jerseys were like
the fashion thing and I wore a bunch of
them on teams I didn't know and then I
found out like Mario Lemieux was like a
fan of Living Color and he gave us he
gave me a gave me a [__] Jersey I was
like I still don't like your sport
um I you know I don't like it either but
you know in my in my dotage I have
learned that the hockey that people
watch today is in great part because of
the uh escaped enslaved people who when
they went North went to [__] Canada
and there was a place called Afric town
that you know they had a hockey league
that yes people play and so the black
people started their own League it was
like a church league and they're the
ones who invented slap shots and the
black right the ones who invented
checking like
did you read the book Black on Ice no I
never did there's a book
um there's a friend of mine Michael
Williams used to work for much music in
Canada uh hit me to this book called
black on ice and I don't have it near me
but it's about that story of how modern
day hockey
owes it's a great deal to you know
escaped slaves from from South of the
Border that came up and and started
making this making this game a little
more interesting
you know icing
all of it you know there's a bunch of
stuff that that yeah it still doesn't
make me want to go out and play it
though
I don't care how black it is right on
got my fist in the air you go for it do
what you want to do I'm not dude this
has been your black history moment with
Mark and Corey
where we explain to you that the thing
that you love that you think was super
white is actually crazy black very also
meet most of American culture but
oh
before I before we digress too deeply
until I don't know say football uh
definitely basketball but
um were you were you growing up were you
a Marvel kid or a DC kid
started out as a Marvel guy because
I one day
I don't know how this happened there was
a house being rebuilt and I don't know I
walked through this house and I found
these old like underneath some
floorboards somewhere somebody had
stashed a bunch of Superman annuals from
1956.
and I was transfixed by these books and
I was reading them I was reading I was
reading them and
I was I wasn't old enough to understand
what I had in my hands really and I
traded them for Marvel books which
looked a lot better so
so I was then hooked on Marvel books
because I because they're like wow this
is this the the industry has gone Leaps
and Bounds since 1957 obviously but like
somebody gave me
like in Iron Man from like 76
I don't I don't know who was doing those
books
but the attention to detail and all that
stuff was just incredible incredible to
me it was like television in a book
and I I'll just and I've been hooked on
Marvel ever since
yeah I mean I think you know especially
as a New York kid there was always
something about Marvel that like you
could go to Greenwich Village and find
the segment Sanctuary you could maybe go
and find the Baxter building or you know
Stark Tower like that [__] was real The
Daily Bugle was in the flat iron
building like you could go
right I saw like I've been to you know
Forest Hills Queens and I that's I know
Spider-Man's around there somewhere you
know
whereas like Metropolis is like it's
kind of New York and Gotham is also kind
of New York but right it's you know it's
not it's not the real real right right
you know
when you saw like I got into Luke Cage
and it's like okay that's not Linux
Avenue but it's close enough I get it I
get what you're trying to do it's not
close
but you're in Harlem at least at least
you're in Harlem and I like I know where
Harlem is right it was it was the Harlem
that had never been visited by many of
the artists who were drawing Harlow
exactly right exactly I was up there and
I I got a Vibe I've seen pictures yeah I
I don't go past 96th Street but yeah
it's over there somewhere yeah 125th uh
that's that's I don't know what the
train goes that high
right what is that what was that movie
that uh was it Jim Jarvis it was a
brother from another planet oh yeah
yeah he says you want to see all the
white people disappear next stop 125th
Street and everybody gets off all the
white folks get off the train
all right yeah see I asked you that
question eight because I was curious oh
and I had an idea I didn't inkling
giving the New York of it all I feel
like all New Yorkers were Marvel Comics
fans right to a certain degree
um at least it was their first exposure
but that will that will dictate the
order in which we talk about the
trailers that dropped during the Super
Bowl are you are you are you are you a
sports ball person did you watch the
Super Bowl I did not I did not watch the
Super Bowl but I was and neither did my
children
don't care we're all Geeks and it was
like we were driving around and I was
like wow there's nobody on the road
today I wonder oh yeah that thing is on
right we should go to some museums or
something no lines to Nowhere
there's the roads are free we can speed
everywhere cops are around let's go so
uh yeah because we there were three
trailers that dropped three big ones I'm
not gonna count the little car
commercial that the Transformers rise of
the Beast trailer was right but we had
uh The Flash the the first real look at
the flash at the Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 their first full trailer for that
right and then we had uh maybe the
biggest superhero movie of them all fast
X which right everybody in those movies
are [__] mutants at this point
obviously because they can't die can't
die you know physics don't apply to them
you know maybe maybe Decades of inhaling
NOS has changed their genetic structure
and they're all just needed right well
Vin looks a little different
okay here's the thing
I knew Vin Diesel when he was the
bouncer at this club in New York called
area
he doesn't remember me
but I remember him because that was that
voice was was very distinct even then
and
um one time I was trying to get into the
club with a friend of mine it was my
manager at the time and he was like and
I was like I'm on the list it's like no
your name is not on the list it's like
look again it's not on the list
and
my friend guy was like
tell him where you're from Corey because
this is getting tiresome it's like high
I'm from the bad Living Color and Ben
looked at looked up and like looked me
in the eye it's like and then get that
look a shock and he's like come on in
come on
but yeah that that was uh so to watch
the rise of Vin Diesel has been a very
interesting thing
I can imagine I can imagine you were you
know Windows to to wonder like right guy
all right
good for you go on with your bad self
right
um all right so then let's let's talk
about Fast and the Furious volume 10.
okay are you a fast person
it is not because it just
it's just like a lot
there's a lot of cliches and cars and
[Music]
like
I was never that cool I always wanted to
be that cool I was one I wanted a fast
car and never had a fast car always had
a very sensible used car that I always
bought and I've never I could never get
into a fast car burning pot like a
Mustang one time I was like you're gonna
kill yourself because you can't drive
you're gonna die in that car you need to
get rid of it
you you didn't learn to drive until you
were in your 20s you don't need that car
you're in the 30s I'm sorry you were in
your 30s when you learned how to drive
you don't need that car
um I I I am a fast person uh
in in every sort of way but uh
I've I've never seen a film series
warp itself in so many different ways
like it started as like a Point Break
rip-off right like pretty blonde kid
goes undercover amongst the the bad guys
doing bad [__] masquerade street racing
culture and it's just a cops and robbers
movie like that's it you know on the
cover am I gonna get blown am I not I
fell in love with this guy's sister I
really like him but oh no we gotta race
once and like that's it
and by like the ninth movie they're
going to space
I've never seen a movie series do this
I've never seen I mean I've seen 25 Bond
movies I've seen right 31 Marvel movies
they always began we're going to space
like that's cool like [__] Tony Stark
it's the upper atmosphere in Iron Man
why like we know what that is
but
this [__] muscle head mechanic is
suddenly like piloting rocket ships and
shooting submarines and yanking
helicopters out of the sky
yeah it's it's it's so fantastic and you
know I think the only movie that I
actually saw was Tokyo Drift
I think I think I saw it in its entirety
and I didn't fall asleep on
um strong and I was like
this doesn't make any sense either this
I understand that this is based on
something that's going on on another
franchise but this makes no sense
they're going to fall off these Cliffs
somebody's gonna die
someone's gonna die and nobody dies 20
cars turn over six seven eight ten times
nobody does no it's a joke cartoon where
it's just like you shoot the plane and
it's like everyone's got a parachute
that pops out of it
don't worry about it we can't kill
anybody on Channel 11. it's three
o'clock in the air at three o'clock in
the afternoon right
I don't know yeah like I I don't know
what it is I think I think I just I love
the inherent daffiness of it and I love
how they double down they are never
afraid to be as dumb as it is
and like all right sure what are we
doing now okay space why not dinosaurs
yeah that's 11 sure time travel hope so
yeah I I I I I was told that there's
some time travel in one of these other
episodes of episodes
for these other movies of fast and
furious and I don't understand how that
happens do they go faster than the speed
of light and go backwards or something
what happened I mean you know we'll get
to The Flash in a bit but yeah yeah
we'll get to that in a minute
did that happen the the time travel
happened in one of the Fast and Furious
it has not yet I mean there's been
flashbacks to [__] but they've never
like uh we got to go hashtag family and
save them from the past I am Groot
right uh no they haven't done it yet but
again everything is possible like
there's like if at one point like in one
of these movies they pull the [__]
tarp off for the car that you're
supposed to race in and it's the
DeLorean like from Back to the Future
like and there's [__] doc brass like
I got it for you Finn
you gotta go back to save tomorrow
oh my God
nothing's nothing is off the table
nothing is off the table huh nope I mean
it better not be at this point
they went to [__] space man they went
to space all of that said I'm gonna see
this movie I'm gonna see it like opening
day because I'm not a cat of course you
are of course I am you know it's and
it's it seems to be like the greatest
hits of them like everybody who has ever
been in one of these movies except for
Dwayne Johnson seems to be back for this
one
now my understanding is that this is a
two-parter yes
right fast X2 it sounds like some
heartburn medicine
um
it's it's
like so everybody is gonna be in the
first one and the Rumor Mill is that
nobody really dies of course because
nobody dies but the second one fast X2
Electric Boogaloo will be just have
Dwayne Johnson in it
just him
just him yeah it's like it's the fast X
we get everybody wanted fast X2 one of
these does not play well with others
right
right so we're letting we're gonna find
find him under some Rebel he's gonna
break that like what do you break his
arm in one of them and then oh yeah
Daddy's got to go to work and he just
snaps it out of a splint
um yeah it looks big it looks as dumb as
humanly possible
um but it's it's [__] catnip to me so
I'ma be there
um let's talk about uh let's let's keep
Vin in the mix and talk about uh
Guardians of the Galaxy volume three
right are you a Guardians dude I am I am
and I read the books back in the day
and
and it was like
that Steve ditko did those did a bunch
of those books didn't he yeah I mean I
think ditko did go and and Kirby I think
touched a lot of that era of early a
really Marvel and I think was it [__]
so one of the image Founders did it also
um
not toddler no I was thinking Joe why am
I blanket on his name
um
but yeah yeah yeah yeah it was yeah that
was that that was an acid trip those
books were
just the backgrounds I don't know
how you got to do those backgrounds and
keep a story in in your head
because you look at the store you look
at the backgrounds you go uh it's just
you just mesmerized by it all
and then
and then there's this story involved and
Eagle The Living Planet says something
speaks it's a planet it speaks I don't
get it Jim Valentino I think this is a
guy who was in on on Guardians really
early right
um yeah no it was it was all like hey we
all met drugs in the 70s and then we
made comic books
right it's like remember that Acid Trip
well here it is
yep welcome to dormammu why because
because
just because so many mushrooms
um yeah I I was never a big Guardians
fan in the comics
um it just didn't yeah I was there was
too much in the X-Men and Spider-Man and
I never swing the guardian's way but I
very much loved the first Guardians
movie like I did you know the tone is
just right on point you know it's
emotional you understand why you know
Peter Quill is the way he is to
understand the hole that's in his heart
and how he fills it with this brag tag
band of morons and [__] right and
each of them needs the other in order to
find a way to be complete you know and
it's fun you know I think that that that
Marvel movies have have always been fun
ish but there's there's a sense of like
there was a heaviness to the MCU by the
time that the Guardians have come around
yeah and it was definitely necessary it
was a good it was
it was a good palette cleanser yeah from
all the destruction and this the first
one at least was before Ragnarok I think
before they decided it means that this
needs to be needs to lighten up and you
got some real sort of levity
out of just
just [__] ups you know just the biggest
the biggest fuck-ups in the world and
how they how they fell up
you know yeah I mean it is also the
story of the least qualified white dude
in the universe
oh it is an impossible white man's story
most of them are most of them are
um but yeah like on the heels of like
winter soldier on the heels of like I
think it comes out after
um
after uh Ultron so like yeah that was
that was the weight of the world it's
all very [__] heavy and this is just
just [__] rock music and we're
bouncing and we're right cracking jokes
and uh and and I I very much dug the
first one it was the van
Wilderness
yeah that's what it was oh deep cut deep
cut
uh minus the Ryan Reynolds of it all but
right yeah dear your other Ryan Reynolds
um the second one I didn't I didn't love
quite as much you know like the the
bounce was still there but the
father-son story didn't quite gel for me
in in the way that that I that I'd hoped
it would
and I think there's something always uh
magnetic about the finale of the story
right the ending of a thing what you
choose to be the last song on your album
what what it says about the the other
stuff that had come before and so it
looks it looks like it's still got a
sense of humor it looks like it's still
got that sort of love between the
characters even though they've gotten
like the new Gamora in there who has no
care whatsoever about Peter Quill and
like that's correct attention
um but it looks like it's in the hands
of like this is James Gunn's probably
his last Model it's his last Guardians
movie this is the last time he's gonna
play with these characters
and so there's a feeling that like he
took it as seriously as you can take a
jokey ROM through space
yeah and you know there's there are a
bunch of sight gags that you can
definitely deal with but you and
particularly in that trailer when they
the whole thing with the high
evolutionary and the rocket is gonna get
really dark and really deep and very
serious
very quickly and you're gonna go
um it's you're gonna you're gonna feel
like you felt when you saw the eternals
like no I'm no amount of jokes was
saving that that thing yeah you know no
and I think it's I I'm gonna go out on a
limb maybe I'm not by myself on this
limb I'm not sure but I do think that
rocket is some of the best work Bradley
Cooper's ever done I agree you know I
agree so much [__] pathos so much
humor so much gravitas like I could
watch I could watch him do that
character right
um I agree
I I think that that
without have he doesn't have his
handsomeness to hide behind in that with
that character no you know he doesn't
have to be he's not a pretty boy he's
anything but a pretty boy and all the
ugliness that he can muster and he is
coming out of that character yeah all
the ugliness that a beautiful person
who's never been ugly can bring to me
right right exactly why they call it
acting I'm pretending to be ugly on the
inside right
um but yeah no I'm I'm here for it it's
it's and it's just me like it this this
year is barreling along and look it's
[__] like this weekend is Ant-Man
quantumania in like two months we get
this another month after that we get the
the Marvels like right there's spoiling
is rotten and like as much as I'm as
much as I do feel occasionally can you
guys slow it down a little bit like it's
it's hard for me to be nostalgic for a
thing I get all the time
right
um I I don't I don't know what they what
that scheduling is about like I could
wait
I could have waited another year for for
black panther I could have waited
literally I could have waited another
year I wasn't chomping at the bit and
and quite honestly it would have given
you more time to really flesh out that
story
and put all the thing all the pieces in
it that you needed if you needed another
year if you wanted to put it out in 2023
and push everything else back it'd have
been great it's been fine as far as I'm
concerned yeah you know and also like
the the Black Panther movies have always
been a little bit siled you know in that
there are not a ton of tendrils that
affect the rest of the MCU person like
once you establish the Black Panther
once you establish wakanda it is not as
if I mean and yes 100 you know the more
is going to be a player in the MCU going
forward but it doesn't sound like he's
in quantumania doesn't sound like he's
gonna be in the Marvels like you could
have to your point like
giving it a little bit more space to
breathe because I know they were all
operating from a place of pain and it's
amazing exactly
and it shows it I think
and and with that they could have pushed
everything else back and and made us
want it more
the fact that that Ant-Man is coming and
that's sort of like the main MCU
storyline and Kang and all that stuff is
coming I get it but
you could have hinted your way into
that story you could have you could have
after credit seeing your way into that
story
waited and waited another year I waited
another six months and everybody would
be like what the [__] is happening and
then you hit him with it because I don't
know um like kids told me that um
and it's not getting really good
is it to get a really good Rotten Tomato
score
so
you could have made it made it a more
anticipatory and then I think you know
Michael got maybe getting the biggest
better score I think we're just getting
piled on with Marvel movies with with
even with with the DCU it's not the DC
EU it's the DCU stuff we're getting
piled on with that as well because we're
gonna get
we're getting the Flash and then we're
getting
um Aquaman and there's something else
right yeah like that's right and then
well first it's it's [__] Shazam then
my flash then I'll come in and then Blue
Beetle all within like 18 months right
and you know it's too much it's you
that's that's a clear shot way of
burning us out on on superhero movies
not me per se but you're a regular
punter out there is gonna go and yeah
another one and they don't know the
difference between Marvel and DC and as
it stands now there are seven superhero
movies coming out in this in the next in
this next nine months
that's a lot yeah
it's a lot especially because you know
people compare into like westerns right
like right that's all they [__] made
in the 50s and the 60s every movie was
in Western but they all weren't like the
same Western they all weren't telling
the same story a great Collective like
well what's John Wayne gonna do this
week's story
how's he gonna touch these five
different movies right was John Ford
gonna gonna put on screen now yeah
totally that's the the Clint Eastwood
connected Universe which right they did
right yeah yeah but you know it didn't
it didn't have the same pressure it
didn't have the same you know regularity
like it went to [__] Italy shot a
bunch of westerns as the man with no
name right you know could they connect
if you want them to do they have to not
necessarily
not necessarily
um and speaking of the last trailer we
got from the Super Bowl the Super Bowl
drop was the Flash
was the uh off debated uh occasionally
um reviled
um I know you feel a certain kind of way
about this movie and because of what's
his name I I feel it yeah you know it's
it's a shame
really because this movie looks great
it's really changed my mind because I
was you know you had convinced me that I
should not see this [__] movie
because it's because [__] are being
[__] and and just leave it alone and
I was like no I'm not gonna see it
because Mark said no no
so I appreciate you implying but I have
any power whatsoever over anything
right and then I saw the trailer
I was like [__] Mark I'm gonna go see
this you know you know like all all
reports had been from everybody who has
seen it for everybody who's close to it
is this movie is great you know we we
have faith in this movie says Warner
Brothers we have faith in these in these
characters we have faith in this
director
I still think the person they have at
the center of this movie
kidnapped children you guys like it is
not an easy thing to overlook thanks to
a couple of press releases and I'm
working on my mental health
there were legit crimes committed by the
star of this film
um and so I'm curious to see
you know a if there is any repercussions
for that if there's any actual you know
charges filed or or or you know trial
set or whatever
but
that said I can I can kind of look hey
we all who have been alive for any
amount of time have discovered that
people who we loved in movies that we
love are awful [__] people
a certain uh gelatinous uh uh putting
salesmen we all knowing new and love was
one of the most prolific rapists in the
world how about that yeah I mean he's a
monster
um I don't imagine that Leonard part 7
is coming anytime soon
so like yeah I I I how one feels about
the Flash and whether or not they want
to support anything that has Ezra
Miller's name on it is a personal
decision for every person all I can say
is that movie looks [__] dope it does
now let me ask you a question do you
think going forward
they're going to stick with him or
they're gonna are they gonna find a way
to replace him or find a way in story to
to get rid of the the actor
I mean they are at the center of a
multiversal story
and so should one want to replace that
person it is 100 possible to do so I
don't know if it's a matter of the next
Flash movie we'll have a different actor
at the center I don't know if it's a
matter of we will
Sunset The Flash for a little bit until
we figure out the rest of the DCU and
notice that in all of the movies that
James Gunn announced none of them were
the flash too even though they've seen
it and they think it's great
um it's entirely possible that it's just
we're gonna let this cool for a while
this is going to do a good a long way
towards kind of resetting and wiping a
little bit of the stink over the DCU
right maybe in 10 years once Ezra has
figured out their issues and once
they've gotten the care and the help
that they need we can revisit returning
him them to the foreign
but yeah like it is just it's it's hard
to watch but I also get it because you
watch them in that trailer and and oh no
they have something
there's an energy and I get it and I
think that
part of what's Happening off screen
for him
is the price of Fame
like he doesn't know what to do with
himself so he was you know I really feel
like
because he's he's concentrating so much
on
the characters and the characters he's
played because
you know
um that Harry Potter movie not Harry
Potter it wasn't Harry Potter but in the
pottery Pottery Universe whatever that
was Fantastic Beasts right
that character
was the only real bright spot in that
movie to me
because because of his performance
because of his acting and his Pathos and
his and his anger like he's like he's
living his life on screen I don't know
what he's doing off screen but well we
kind of do know what he's doing on
screen
but
you could see that he's putting all of
whatever it is that's going on with him
on screen
yeah yeah I mean and
it's it is a difficult problem I think
for Studio to deal with it's a different
it's difficult sort of moral issue for
the viewership to deal with absolutely
and you know it's it's the same it's
it's similar to the issue that I think
people are having we have to to to
piggyback off of your your comment the
Harry Potter video game
which is right right do I play a game
based on a universe created by a woman
who seems to not believe that trans
people exist exactly or at least that
trans people have the rights that
everybody else should have right and and
like if you want to play that game play
that game like it is your choice to make
as a person who can do what you want to
do but you've got to figure that part of
the problem out for yourself
and I think that that part of put
because they did supposedly put a trans
character in into the game
but
as that's that was that was the game
developers not
um JK Rowling
and but it just seems a day late and a
dollar short
yeah for anybody yeah you know so it's
it is always the issue of a do you let a
person
um redeem themselves do you allow for a
Redemption story do you do you allow for
a person to get better than they happen
to have been when they did this you know
who gets to have Grace uh who gets to to
to to be able to to work on themselves
in the way that as a society we hope you
would can they rehabilitate themselves
I'd like to hope so I'd like to hope
everybody can I I do too but you know
there's also a
a forgiveness gap
for in from the highest echelons to the
lowest there's like once you're an
[__] you're always an [__] and
you're never going to not be an [__]
no matter what you do to rehabilitate
your your your character in some way
because we might not we don't believe
your sincerity that you're doing this
just so that you can continue to stay in
the public eye and you know
and we've fashioned ourselves off
in a real way to like
I can't I can't support her
because she's a turf and I can't support
him
because
he is
he's he's harming children
you know and no and and they can't find
a middle ground for any of it
and we and we we spend our days online
doing that and maybe it's a maybe it's a
function of the internet to
to sort of compartmentalize your your
ideas about people but
we gotta something's got to give in my
opinion I mean yeah that there has to be
some path forward that allows that
people change because they do right they
can only change because they want to
change you can't force the people to be
to get first person to be it comes in
there not
um I bet you there are a lot of women
who would say that about their husbands
I married this person thinking they
would change I tried to change them they
didn't they did not and now you know
we're getting a divorce or you know vice
versa
the change has to be internal and has to
be genuine and sincere and in that case
like yeah if a person does the work then
all right it's like prison you go to
prison and you pay your debt to society
and you come out a better person on the
other side that's supposed that's what's
supposed to happen that's that's that's
what it was designed to be right and it
was designed to rehabilitate somebody
from by taking them out of society so
they can learn how to how to be a part
of society
and we've we've cordoned people off and
never to return again no matter what
they do no matter how they work
treated
um and
it's a it's there's a subtlety to this
there's a Nuance to this that we're not
really getting
on some in some cases yeah almost never
because Nuance was the first thing to go
when social media became the way we
communicated and the way we get our
information you can't get Nuance in 140
characters no no
um all right listen we are all gonna see
these movies because of course we are
we're nerds of course we are that's what
we do that's what we do
um we are going to talk about the last
of us
um in the episodes four and five in just
a second but first
I'm gonna pay some bills
um all right you know and and Corey you
can you can 100 be an interesting
bystander while I sell some smell Goods
okay yeah yeah
um this episode of uh black man beyond
as many fat men's are uh before it was
brought to you by the good Folks at the
native
um when it comes to Valentine's Day hey
we're all about the candy
um we're all about [__] Reese's
Peanut Butter Cups well about M M's the
ones with peanuts in them we're all
about twixes we're all about the joy and
that's why I am loving Natives New
Limited Edition Candy Shop collection
like all Native products they are
thoughtfully formulated to keep me and
you smelling and deliciously feeling and
smelling deliciously fresh all day long
you know them for their aluminum free
deodorant native keeps their ingredients
unless bare naked with ingredients you
understand like coconut oil shea butter
and baking soda checks a lot of boxes
72-hour order protection naturally
derived ingredients in a smooth
residue-free application they also offer
a variety of scents with new and limited
edition since being released all the
time like gummy bears strawberry vanilla
Taffy sour Berry belt I said it right
this time
um Whitney Houston native I stumble on
sour say almost there again
uh as last episode just forget it
couldn't get it done but now we killed
it until you made me do it again thanks
Corey no problem when you use native you
will smell amazing all day long thanks
to their long lasting scents want to
smell spicy and woodsy sweet or clean
and fresh native has a center option for
everyone
so now is the time to make the switch
from Andy person to Native when you
visit their site you can discover all
their first sense and maybe even try out
one of their body washes while you're at
it so right now go to nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code Fatman at
checkout to get a sweet 20 off your
first order that's nativedeo.com Fatman
or use a promo code Fatman at checkout
for 20 off your first order
thank you to the good Folks at the
native for sponsoring this episode of
the podcast
it's great I'm gonna do it you did it
you did it congratulations fantastic
excellent we got one native guys we did
it you did it
um Last of Us last one is last of us we
are not we are not good folks uh viewers
at home going to spoil too much of it
um again it's been a it's been a minute
like you've had him you had since last
Friday it's a few days
um we're also not gonna do q a today
because uh all of us middle-aged men are
going to go off and do Valentine's Day
yes with the people who have for some
reason chosen to love us
um don't ask me why yeah it's a mystery
the great mystery of life
um worry are you a gamer
I am I am but I did not play the last
one was one of my sons did he he played
it and is watching this show as well so
I get clued in on oh that's a cut scene
or that's gameplay and I didn't expect
to see one of those and and when they do
it on television that didn't make any
sense in the game now it's on now on the
screen
uh how are you feeling about the show uh
in total now that we're more than
halfway through it I'm loving this show
I think you know
um Pedro Pascal
is the farrier of children evidently
that's his job as an actor he takes
children from one place to another
and that's that's that's who he is and
it's going to it's either going to be
like Dune or candle Cannonball run but
it's he's going to be there
taking care of the the wee ones and and
getting them the way they need to be and
he's amazing at it he's really really
sort of the the stoicness but the
emotion behind his eyes that you can see
is incredible is incredible
and the last couple episodes you you see
what you're seeing now is with Joel sort
of ramping up his emotional height thing
and Ellie's sort of lowering hers
is very very interesting and see where
the I want to see where they meet in the
middle of this and I guess we won't see
that until the very end
yeah I mean it's it's it's the story of
a guy who does not want to be a father
again who finds himself in this position
and a young woman who has never had a
father who doesn't really know how to
react to it and so as he warms to her
and you know the end of the end of 104
um I mean most of most of the fourth
episode you know felt a bit you know
action adventure right felt like a
post-apocalyptic drama
where we are rolling into Kansas City
that's you know walled off there's
there's [__] Thugs and gangs and
armed guys and waiting to pray on the
weak and like can we survive in this
town that's just run by
Melanie lynskey who's like the worst
Cameron that ever Karen wow wow super
Karen wow super dupe like like such a
wow that's the she was the most
like I've seen her in other things it's
like oh she's sweet and she's pleasant
but wow she's menacing and scary as hell
oh hell yes I mean I I worked with her
on Castle Rock and she's she's a lovely
person but there's only imagine there is
a there is a deep well that she can draw
from and like when she puts it on when
she decides she wants to be scary it's
still in the guys
of what looks like you know she's a PTA
mom you know she feels kind of like you
know she'd be she'd be a lovely person
to have coffee with unless you [__]
with her in which case she will shoot
you in the face right and then cut your
balls off and keep them in her pocket
absolutely
um you know the thing that that that you
know this this these two episodes this
sort of paired couple
um is Joel and Ellie specifically Joel
encountering uh another
pair-bonded couple of people who have
found
or have built or inherited the kind of
love he's never had you know first it
was Frank and Bill you know who had the
world's most perfect love even when it
was shitty even when they had their bad
days they were meant for each other they
were each other's purpose
you know Joel's purpose you know died in
his arms you know 22 years ago or
whatever that was
um and so in in episode three he
encounters that deep like committed love
and here he encounters you know with
with Henry and Sam
Another Kind of pair-bonded Love Story
of right here's this older brother
caring for his younger brother but for
all intents and purposes it is a father
and son the the the age Gap is enough
that you could potentially buy that and
they are perfectly bonded together they
desperately need each other they they do
not exist or could not function without
each other and here comes Joel who's
just figuring out how to [__] laugh
again after 20 years of being in the
boneyards right you know and uh and and
once again you know again we're not
gonna like deep spoil but spoil a little
bit
um catastrophe befalls
um this couple
you knew something bad was gonna happen
you you you were assured that anybody
that they come in that Ellie and Joel
come in contact to come contact with are
going to be Pro are going to have
problems that they couldn't surmount
yeah but every time it's such a
heartbreaking
place to be it's just
wow
how do you drag my heart through the mud
yet again
within two episodes of the last time you
did it
for a good thing
yeah oh it's just
like I was getting it's like I can't be
too happy I can't be so happy this can't
be too that good it can't be that good
and of course this isn't that good an
episode and a half later it's all in
terms of [__] wow in terms of [__] you
know and and we we've talked a bit
before on on this podcast about the game
with some 20 25 hours long that
experience and so you know and the Frank
and Bill story was drastically different
in the game like there was no absolutely
yeah
um but yeah Henry and Sam it it also
hits hard in the game
um the characters are slightly different
in the game Sam is not deaf
um you know wow straight up talks you
know
um and the the desire in listening to
Craig Mason on the official podcast
talking about how do I differentiate
these this kid from Ellie like they're
about the same age they would have the
same kind of pitter patter the same
youthful resistance to Authority I just
didn't want to have the same two kids
talking to each other and to everybody
else and so the solution was like all
right well what if he can't talk you
know what if that what if the tenor of
those conversations are incredibly
different by virtue of the fact that
they have to be right and they cast a
young deaf actor
um you know who's fantastic amazing
absolutely amazing I mean both of them
both both actors Henry and Sam were
really you could see
the Pathos in both of them and like the
worry that Sam Henry had for Sam and and
by contrast this worry that Sam had for
Henry yeah
um was always there and
just so beautiful so [__] beautiful
yeah
yeah and because in the game you know it
takes a
the span of the game is so long those
things are not back to back like you're
living with the gaming in the world for
longer than you are in the show and so
the show is going to have to like these
big things will happen every episode
we're going to find ways to break Arts
everywhere right
yeah it's it's like
the whole idea that this was sort of
like some light-hearted video game
is completely squashed by the show it's
like this is this isn't and it sort of
gives
uh Gamers good bad or indifferent
a
it makes you think of them very
differently now it's like you're dealing
with with real life stories in this game
so you maybe you are equipped for the
real world you know I mean it's it's a
game as it is a show that's about love
and all of the ways that love affects
people and sometimes those ways are not
great
sometimes those ways are painful
sometimes they destroy you
um sometimes they drive you to do things
you would never ordinarily do because
you love a thing or a place right of
life or a status or whatever that is
um and so what are the things that at
the end of the day Joel will do for love
and how wonderful and awful are those
going to be
um
and it's it's profound in that way the
game is a profound experience and so far
the the show is proving to be similarly
so absolutely absolutely and you know
you could see
at the end of the these episodes at the
end of this whole series this this this
one season
it you will never feel the same
like you'll be changed by the show
that's what I'm what I'm what I've seen
very much so for those who like actually
watch the show they are changed by the
show that maybe the game didn't really
change and really didn't do it because
it was a game and you could turn it off
and you could do that
but
the conversation that everyone is having
about the show is that they are
ultimately Changed by the idea of what
love can do for you good pattern and
different that's that this whole series
is going to change the the com is
changing the conversations about
the world we live in to a large degree I
think and you know for those who are in
fact watching it and goes over watching
it intently we'll see that that that
they come it will change the
conversation
yeah I mean I think that this show is to
video games what Watchmen the show was
the comic books and it it's it's taking
from The Source material and both being
faithful to it and drastically
reinterpreting it naturally finding a
new thing to say about it then the
original story was
um in ways that come through reinvention
and come through just iteration and come
through the change in mediums
um but I think it's fascinating that
some of the most deeply human
storytelling is coming as adaptation
from sources that aren't usually
traditionally referred to as the human
absolutely yeah
yeah but the whole idea of dealing with
your Humanity
and what Humanity what
has Humanity done to you and what have
you done to humanity is on display right
there on that in that show that's about
a game it's about it it's about a game
that you play late at night till four
o'clock in the morning yeah I've done it
I've been that guy I've been that guy
um uh before we let you go and before we
wrap up for this day
um we wanted to talk a little bit about
um a a seminal artist who passed away
um
just a couple days ago right who I had
referenced in the open as part of my
Holy Trinity of artists who helped me
discover who I was and who I was going
to be
um but true boy the dove plug two uh
David juliker from uh De La Soul
uh passed away at age 54. um well the
cause of death has not been revealed yet
um but far far too young
um tragedy in the way that that you know
all young deaths are tragedies
um but you know there was something a
little bit more I'm not even gonna call
it Bittersweet but you know Dayla was on
the verge of recapturing their masters
their rights to their own music and yeah
they had their music back like you
hadn't been able to stream you hadn't
been able to it was impossible to do so
because of you know law you know record
company Shenanigans and they got it back
in March they were about to you know
release it back into the world again
they were going to go on tour again yeah
you know all of the the the financial
windfalls that could be theirs was on in
the off
um absolutely absolutely and I remember
there was this conversation a smaller
one you know us old heads always knew
how great they were but when uh three is
the magic number ended up in the closing
credits to to Spider-Man
um no way home right and you're like oh
this [__] this bangs where's the rest
of my day last Soul well this [__] is
great where let me dust off my cassette
player and my cassette single fine three
feet high and rising and play that [__]
again yeah yeah you know and so to to
watch an audience a mass audience kind
of ReDiscover just how wonderful that
music was how joyful it was how
effervescent it was how you know and
what other issues were that they sampled
so [__] heavily but so mystically
that clearing and these samples
anything there's a thousand samples in
this song how do we pay for all of this
[__] right
um but it's such gorgeous music and uh
and and I don't know what happens to De
La Soul at this point I don't know if it
if if they become the way the beasties
did and just said you know what right
with the three of us and without that
third remember we are not the Beastie
Boys and so whether or not you know Mesa
Dove and and pause the news decide they
want to continue
um
I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know
but yeah it was it was very sad news
um to encounter over the weekend
absolutely you know and but you guys
were contemporaries you guys we were
yeah I was telling you earlier like
their first show in New York was opening
for us at The Ritz in New York City like
based on
that first record coming out and really
sort of blowing up in New York and we
were on you know
and we wanted to give them as much shine
as they possibly could and they were
really really good really good guys I
hung out with Dave a lot and uh they're
good people they were just good people
and they're all really good people and
um
I'm hoping
that
this doesn't diminish or
the efforts they did to get this record
out because they they spent a great deal
of time they had put out GoFundMe and
try trying to get enough money so they
can get there so they can get their
masters back that this will not
deter people going out and getting this
record I hope that I hope that it makes
I hope it makes the money that they
wanted to make I hope that it gives them
the recognition that they deserve
at some point and and
you know unfortunately it's it's tragic
but it might help you know you never
know you never know but um but yeah like
it's I hope it is not the end of the
daisy age yes because you know the inner
sound y'all it deserves to be heard
right
um and so so yeah just pouring one out
for for True boy the dove absolutely who
uh who helped to change my life in good
ways
um and I think I don't think I'm alone
um the music was extraordinary
um absolutely so and at the very least
we have that yes or at least we have
yeah
um this has been a wonderful [__]
hour and a half of black man beyond we
we have we've traversed the globe we
went to to Japan and Buenos Aires and
North to Canada to talk about nerd [__]
and hockey we then backed around to
movie trailers and delicious smelling
soaps thank you native
um and then you know ended let's try
that body wash oh dude they got one that
makes you smell like vanilla cookies
oh see I can't do that to get hungry
I'm trying not to be a fat guy that's
all you know you know well hey you know
but sometimes you just gotta you gotta
tempt yourself just a little bit oh I
smell delicious today I smell delicious
what is that delicious smell oh that's
me
welcome aboard everybody
uh Corey thank you so much for breaking
off some time uh on your Valentine's Day
um thank you to just [__] do it out
with me man hey no problem I wouldn't
have it any other way what I wanted to
do for a very long time and hang out
with you and like I said are saying to
JC I'm coming to LA
beginning of next month and I'd love to
come see the bar maybe we can go hang
out there do something or have a drink
and I hear the tater tots are good I
just I don't know what it is I just
wanted to thank you
we'll have a night at scum and villainy
and uh and we will set the place on fire
hey there we go metaphorically
metaphorically we will not actually set
your place the insurance is paid for
though right Jay yeah I mean might not
be the worst idea
I mean
fire and is is can be fixed but you know
never mind never mind it's cleansing
it's yes as far as cleansing
um where uh where can the people find
you on the internet what do you got
coming up what do you want to what do
you want to toss to
um you can find me on Instagram just
look up my name I'm out I'm out there
I'm uh on Twitter but I don't I don't
post anything on Twitter
ever not even before that was [__] I
never just never did because I don't
understand Twitter
um I don't get it
um
and yeah mostly I'm on Instagram and
there's a Living Color page on Instagram
is Living Color website you can go to
that you can get our gear you can get
records and all kinds of stuff just come
check us out we're we're we are around
outstanding
um
Corey thank you so much for being here
Mark man it's my pleasure and I'd love
to do this again and like I said when I
get out there and like two weeks I'm
gonna hang out excellent hit me up all
right we'll we'll do it right you got it
and this has been another episode of
black man beyond uh my name is Mark
Bernardin um and we will see you same
black Time same black Channel
smodcast.com or youtube.com Kevin Smith
be good everybody
listen to dinner sound y'all that's
right peace
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]